this orlando i uh love this guy
this guy i met him i met him at a party
i know he talks about you all the time
and he and you know i told him i was
coming on the show and he's like oh yeah
me and howard we we like our best
friends i mean he thinks that you guys
like have such great rapport
with each other we do i think the same
thing we were at this party
and uh i don't know he's sitting there
you know how [ __ ] handsome he is
i'm like sitting there going like oh
jesus that's why i'm in this mess
yeah i'm like no exactly oh my god i
mean how can you resist
but i was teasing him about his penis
picture the famous penis picture where
you guys were on vacation somewhere
and he is nude like you're not nude he's
nude
well he tried to get me there and i was
like nah did you know not to be nude
because you
knew somebody was gonna get a picture of
that right
i mean i i wouldn't have never like
set him up you know like if i had a real
thought but like
in my in the back of my mind i'm like
yeah this i
you know i am jim carrey in the truman
show a little bit
so i feel like you know maybe
there would be a chance i'm i'm the more
i guess i would say
i'm a little bit more of the pragmatic
in the part in the partnership
did you ever say to him listen orlando
what's the point of being naked on a
paddle board or whatever canoe i mean
you know well it was europe i mean it
was europe and like
honestly and honestly like we had had a
pretty chill
time for a week and
um you know everywhere we looked it was
like it was like everybody was naked it
was europe
it was it was italy and i think he
wanted to fit in with the locals
right and it was the end of the trip
he's like one of the best-looking guys
i've ever seen in person but um he was
he
he was uh like days before it was
talking about twitter
and some statistics about like pirates
of the caribbean or
lord of the rings just you know in good
fun and i was like i roll i
roll i roll and then all sudden he is
number one trending on twitter and i was
like how